foreign
Federal authorities have initiated a
Manhunt for William butcher kicking
things off with some previously unused
position and narration communication is
everything eventually we'll know what's
going on here but right now it's just
distracting and hard to give a [__]
about when I just want to get back to
the people that were literally just
inside a whale details are still
emerging about the soup Terrace
newspaper previously awning after the
previous previously on news position and
narration had who keeps writing this
[__] no one can debate that New Yorkers
owe their lives to the brave actions
taken by Stormfront your fake news
doesn't know how to debate correctly
this cabin manages to both over candle
and over lamp who produced this show
anyway illumination delivering liquid to
someone's mouth hole with your feculent
draggled hand wieners having a giraffe
for a grandmother I ever tell you about
my recurring dream I'm on stage I'm not
giving someone a chance to lie and
answer yes so they don't have to listen
to your stupid dream that no one cares
about we can't have Anonymous skull
exploding assassins walking around being
okay with well-known skull exploding
assassins walking around
missed our best guess where she is
telling someone you have the thing they
care about most and then pausing before
saying well actually I'm just guessing
I'm sorry
a lot before
coincidentally that amount of time is
exactly the amount of time the writers
thought we would buy this [__]
scenario storming it off the books vot
compound alone how is it possible that
you're dumber than you look Marvin T
milk would be lactose intolerant at TV
sins
don't want him to get snow all over me
jacket me jacket can we talk about
homelander shoulder Eagles for a second
not only are those things ugly as Sin
but they are completely impractical HL
would be catching those things on all
sorts of stuff throughout his day and
accidentally maiming his co-workers just
by turning around near them as if
homelander needs a reason to
accidentally maim his co-workers
intentionally lingering on the number of
the floor homelander got off on as an
attempt to get me to say nice but also
nice she like an Almond Joy
removing the joy because you're allergic
to almonds the screens of this show are
the bullshittiest [__] should ever
be shot out of a bowl what even is all
this mess and how would it be helping
anyone in this room in the slightest the
creators were like just put a bunch of
small stuff on there so the jerks over
TVs can't read it or send it well first
you have greatly underestimated us and
also stop calling us TVs look Andy they
take time
how much time I'm guessing the time it
will take will be strangely connected to
how strong the ratings of the show
remain
guess so I have a second cousin who
lives around there I could tell VA that
I'm
at a visit tricking the most powerful
company in the world with literal
superheroes on its payroll with the old
second cousin routine seriously the
amount of disbelief the show wants me to
suspend just so Starlight and Huey can
get some hang time together is
astronomical also I Know What You Did
Edible Arrangements papyrus
isn't fought for tux it's new fitness
Outreach for toddlers being a new
fitness Outreach for toddlers instead of
the long-awaited reveal about how they
recruit babies into their soup
development program good you're here
because I came here to kick you out of
the seven and boy howdy Isn't it nice
you just happened to be in the room and
already discussing things because you
also just happened to see Shockwave at
the elevators we won't dare Play the
song because we didn't start the fire it
might be powerful enough to force a sin
removal but these two falling in love
against the backdrop of AIDS crack and
Bernie gets makes it seem like they're
not actually hearing the lyrics look on
the sociopolitical satirical front the
show never stops going hard and I can't
help but never stop respecting them for
it have you heard of the lovers of
aldaro no and I also forgot you were
doing these weird zero context when
super Harry Met Sally interview cut in
so I'm all different sorts of confused
right now you smell like a wet dog
misunderstanding the concept of foreplay
are you gonna tell me what's wrong
are you just gonna stain my clean sheets
with your sweaty despair just
understanding the concept of Pillow Talk
what good does grieving all alone ever
do sometimes people are different in the
ways they handle trauma and grief and
different coping mechanisms can have
different levels of efficacy depending
on the oh are you just stating a
rhetorical question with no interest
whatsoever in the nuance and depth of a
possible answer or discussion right
carry on then you take me to Duncan on
the slide and he would get me
chocolate cream filled donut going to
Dunkin for donuts Duncan's for coffee
made me one of those breakfast croissant
sandwiches you're better off going to a
gas station for donuts than Duncan I
mean other than their raspberry felt you
know what guys I might be really hungry
right now having your donuts for three
minutes already and only eating this
much especially considering milk's donut
is somehow still whole even though we
saw him take a big bite earlier and a
second bite from behind any part of your
body and I mean any part that you draw
White
you're not cleaning anything wow that
really contextualized the argument he
had with Frenchie in the first season
you need to eat my clinched [__] but
I wish it didn't would be okay
especially for the guy in the passenger
seat with his arm hanging out of the
window Not only was he not in the line
of impact he didn't even exist a few
seconds ago and that van went much
further off the road than this the
continuity department just take the week
off any place around here
of our million body cameras introducing
this complaint about the age of social
media without giving us the slightest
idea of how he got past a single one of
those million bloody cameras the place
that has no cameras looks like the place
that needs all the cameras who built
this compound
[Music]
well that's it butcher found Becca
primary plot driver complete it's been a
good two seasons sad to see the show go
but none of these two have reunited
there's no way to use any other [__]
to continue on I'm out I'm going out of
the last scraping World thinking past
performance is a guarantee of future
results
I can't climb that fence oh we all know
kids are excellent climbers it's part of
what makes the threat they pose to
society very real
ignoring your sleep apnea
vincenova enjoys in this episode is such
a clear indication of product placement
that it completely takes me out of the
reality of a show that has super powered
beings in it the anti-septic wipes
really you haven't noticed any of this
being that antiseptic wipes are a sign
of OCD as opposed to a sign of being a
person who just wants to clean their
hands I sleep about four hours a night I
wish I slept four hours a night and I'm
too busy two of my fingernails down to
the quick insulubury competitions just
wondering if
homelander is waiting around every
corner to kill me the Comfort at which
this human with one of the most
recognizable faces in the world has
these kinds of conversations at this
volume in a public place is baffling as
Legend has it the top blanket is rarely
washed so they're touching the top
blanket while doing the thing in the
place that is the main reason you should
never touch the top blanket
I got it Starlight uses her internal
dimming switch and now I'm completely
confused about her powers if she pulled
energy from the lamp to do this then the
light should return to normal after she
stops drawing power unless She's
continually drawing power from the lamp
which would make the sin Huey not being
worried about his Huey so he asked me to
get one of these with him not having the
physical capabilities of pronouncing the
word no Rebecca's back already on the
same night how is this not suspicious to
the guards did the writers just bump up
her previously unknown smoking Habit to
a pack a day getting Urban In and Out
Back get it because his name is Carl
Urban and the Outback is the opposite of
the city and he's Australian do you get
it 90 of this episode is pre and
post-coital chats and all the boys get
some except mm well at least he got a
donut
no
not having the mental capabilities of
understanding the word no exactly
Carol [__] Brady all day how dare you
you keep America's mom's [__] name
out your [__] mouth wasted space
seriously you can put like a hundred
Shake Shacks there me and Elena are just
friends Elena and I are just friends
Maeve honestly that's the most offensive
thing I've heard this entire scene look
news position is a Scourge on all media
but in this single episode of a single
TV show this is now the sixth time a
character has received information or
motivation via random news broadcast
just take the leap the boys do an entire
episode that's just news broadcasts at
least that would show a little
creativity
[Applause]
and y'all are just some damn fools
letting a secondary character say the
most authentic and truthful thing in the
history of your show when I was a kid
something happened between my family and
Vlog which I'd rather not talk about but
it was bad this just feels like the
Scripps way of saying I don't want to
pay myself into a corner in case we get
a third season and have to make sure any
of this makes sense a little black girl
accusing a white superhero of murder in
these parts up until this point the
show's been taking on the superior
problem mostly from the perspective of
celebrity and hero worship addressing
unfair power dynamics as they relate to
literal physical strength so finally
seeing how superpowers could collide
with the history of race relations in
America is pretty deep and to be clear I
said deep not the Deep so quickly take
your sin back before I have to give one
to the Deep she's probably dead by now
oh no no
I just haven't had an outdated form of
news delivery here that also just so
happens to have the big reveal that's
directly related to why you came here
that's Liberty so Valerie saw Liberty up
close because she was in the car and
witnessed her brother's murder but if
Liberty was in the public eye enough to
be in Budweiser advert she must have had
enough exposure that other people would
recognize her as well but who knows what
compound V can do oh I know this one
whatever the [__] the show needs it to
do who prepared the meme PowerPoint for
homelander to click through and why also
I don't like a single one of these memes
here's a better one I just came up with
off the top of my head much better right
this constant need to be loved by
everyone is kind of pathetic what I
don't need to be loved by everyone just
a few thousand people on a daily basis
and I should be fine oh you weren't you
weren't talking about me were you you
don't need 50 million people to love you
you need 5 million people [__] pissed
this being true then we have homelander
all over again then there's two [__]
[__] in this world show makes me
long for a world with only two [__]
[__] drinking this many red bulls
and by this many I mean drinking even
one Red Bull also I love how the shows
like show a bunch of empty Red Bulls so
the audience will know they've been
looking through footage for a long time
and it won't make this happening at this
point in the episode not feel so
conveniently timed nice try story
Wizards your magic has no power here
also also in a world full of soups can
Red Bull be sued for false advertising
or does it actually give Wings listen if
you're ever in the mood for another
Almond Joy the title of this episode
should have been Almond Joy presents
news position we've now found out that
these interviews are about finding the
Deeper Life and the only reason we
couldn't have known that sooner so the
episode could pretend to be avant-garde
or some [__] well joke's on you show I
don't even know what an Avant is or why
they're so hard to protect I don't need
anyone but myself
does that negligee just transform with
doppelganger earlier when he couldn't
hold the transformation because he was
tired it was still on him so doesn't
that mean it's an actual physical object
the truth is we're gonna need to see how
that negligee looks on every member of
the seven to really suss this out for
science the back of this body double I
mean doppelganger's hair is visibly
different from the back of homelanders
that's just shoddy craftsmanship but
again if staying changed takes great
effort as mentioned earlier how is
doppelganger efforting as a corpse
shouldn't even change back the second
his neck was broken or was the visual
metaphor a bit too important
oh
look she's cutting up an Almond Joy it
wasn't your fault it's not your fault I
ever tell you about my recurring Dream
well I'd be chased by a giant Listerine
bottle we can't have Anonymous skull
exploding assassins walking around it's
annoying it gets everywhere
mine
don't even hear yourself
my father was a drinker
and a fiend it's been 48 years it's been
84 years and let me tell you right now
it won't work
well if you were me then I'd be you and
I'd use your body to get to the top it's
wrong they care about not us yeah and
then what
and then thought raises him without a
mother right then we have homelander all
over again and there's two [__]
[__] in this world we could
disappear right just start again start a
new family
look at me
look at me I'm the captain now